hey spotify rapt just dropped did you  see that nice hey spotify who was my top  artist this year your top artist this  year was taylor swift and your most  listened to track was staying alive by  the bee gees what  guess i do love that song  what about yours oh i don't i don't use  spotify but uh  uh hey apple music  or i was hoping maybe you could like uh  i could maybe what well you could tell  me some cool data about my favorite  music yeah we barely made it through  2021 i don't think i'm ready to go down  memory lane okay thought it'd be fun if  that would be fun okay here's a  favorites list i'm pretty sure i didn't  listen to most of those songs more than  once what do you want from me what what  do i want from you  i don't know want to listen to some  radio not really